ein deutsches forschungsteam hat jetzt
eine ganz neue klasse von sternen
entdeckt und zwar handelt es sich um
rasende zombie sterne
doch diese sterne sind nicht nur
besonders schnell sondern haben auf
mysteriöse art und weise zudem auch noch
ihre eigene supernova überlegt
normalerweise besiegelt solch eine
explosion ja das ende der stern der
krieg zum science fiction hier gebe es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen heute
übrigens aus dem space wo wir am samstag
live zur mondlandung vor 50 jahren
streamen ab 21 uhr geht's los so
genannte hyper schnellläufer sind echte
ausreißer unter den sternen denn sie
sind so schnell dass sie quasi der
schwerkraft senken der kompletten
galaxie entkommen denn sie rasen mit
unglaublichen geschwindigkeiten von bis
zu 1000 kilometern pro sekunde durch ihr
hohes tempo sind sie sogar in der lage
ihre galaxie zu verlassen anders also
als die sterne der milchstraße die alle
um deren zentrum kreisen weil sie die
gravitation dort festhält unter
fachleuten ist bis heute umstritten wie
diese raser sterne entstehen
möglicherweise erlangen sie durch das
zentrale schwarze loch unserer
milchstraße enormes tempo oder sind sie
womöglich von der supernova ihres
partners sterns aus geschleudert worden
manche experten und expertinnen gehen
dagegen von einem extragalaktischen
ursprung aus und erklären somit die hohe
geschwindigkeit der hyper schnellläufer
ein forschungsteam um den astronom
oberto ruddy von der universität
erlangen-nürnberg hat jetzt drei weitere
raser sterne entdeckt doch diese zeigen
sich völlig anders als die bisher
bekannten sterne dieses typs denn anders
als die meisten bislang identifizierten
raser handelt es sich nicht um blaue
riesen oder sonnenähnliche sterne
stattdessen konnten ruddy und seine
kolleginnen und kollegen herausfinden
dass die neu entdeckten ausreißer
besonders klein sind die drei winzlinge
verfügen über radien von 0,6 bis 0,6
sonnen radeon und auch ihre masse ist
klein sie liegt bei gerade einmal 0,2
bis 0,28 sonnenmassen das deutsche
astronomie team konnte diese
schnellläufer durch die analyse von
daten ausfindig machen die vom
esa-satelliten gaia stammen ihre speck
daten erlaubten dann auch den
rückschluss auf ihre größe und masse
zwei der drei neu entdeckten sterne
befinden sich innerhalb der milchstraße
einer liegt außerhalb die drei neu
entdeckten hyper schnellläufer
unterscheiden sich aber nicht nur
aufgrund ihrer größe und masse von den
bisher beobachteten raser stern auch
ihre zusammensetzung ist völlig anders
denn ihre atmosphäre besteht zu etwa 60
prozent aus nähern zu 30 prozent aus
sauerstoff keine spur dagegen von helium
und wasserstoff wie ansonsten dazu heißt
es in der studie diese merkmale
demonstrieren dass diese sterne
einzigartige aber einander sehr ähnliche
spektrale und kinematischen merkmale
besitzen diese unterscheiden sie von
allen anderen klassen von sterbt
deswegen gehen die fachleute davon aus
dass es sich bei ihrer entdeckung um
eine komplett neue klasse von hyper
schnellläufer handel ähnlichkeit haben
die drei exoten lediglich mit einer
entdeckung aus dem jahr 2017 damals hat
ein forschungsteam den stern lp 40 365
entdeckt ebenso ein exot unter den hyper
schnell läufern nach ansicht der
experten expertin gehört dieser wohl in
dieselbe bisher unbekannte klasse an
hyper schnellläufer wie die aktuelle
entdeckung fraglich aber wie diese
exakte entstanden sind handelt es sich
etwa um überlebende ihrer eigenen
explosion genau dafür sprechen einige
hinweise die jetzt entdeckten sterne
scheinen nämlich tatsächlich ihre eigene
supernova überlebt zu haben
eigentlich ein komplett unmögliches
phänomen so dachte man wenigstens
bislang der bisherigen lehrmeinung
zufolge wird bei dem sogenannten super
nova typ 1a der weiße stern komplett
zerstört sein begleitstern dagegen kann
als superschnell läufer aus geschleudert
werden doch die drei neuen sterne weisen
einen hohen anteil an schweren elementen
auf die typisch sind für weiße zwerge
wie passt also zusammen
die expertinnen und experten schließen
aus diesen beobachtungen dass es wohl
doch möglich ist dass ein weißer stern
solch eine explosion überlebt hat
wenigstens zum teil
den modellen zufolge könnte dabei sogar
bis zu 20 prozent von ihm übrig bleiben
bei seinen überresten könnte es sich
also um die raser sterne handeln dazu
heißt es in der studie von ruddy und
seinem team unsere beobachtungen stützen
die interpretation dass lp 40 365 und
die drei neuen sterne teilweise
verbrannte weiße zwerge sind die die
zerstörung durch eine thermonukleare
supernova überlebt haben dafür spricht
auch dass die neu entdeckten exotischen
raser sterne keinen kohlenstoff
enthalten und das obwohl dies ein
hauptbestandteil weißer zwerge ist nach
ansicht des forschungsteams könnte
dieses element bei der sternenexplosion
verbrannt worden sein den ablauf der
supernova und gleichzeitig auch der
entstehungsmechanismus für die hyper
schnellläufer skizzieren die fachleute
folgendermaßen der weiße zwerg war wohl
in sehr engem abstand um sagen größeren
partner gekreist und hatte ihm material
abgesaugt dieser wurde instabil und
explodierte die fragmente des weißen
zwergs und der partner stern schleuderte
dabei in entgegengesetzte richtung durch
die wucht der explosion wurden die
überreste extrem beschleunigt das
restaurant team ist sich ziemlich sicher
dass sie bei weiteren analysen noch mehr
solcher sterben typen in der milchstraße
aufspüren können
gefunden haben wir ja bereits
mondgestein aber was wäre eigentlich
werden die mondlandung nicht
stattgefunden hätte darüber berichtet
neugier zone dafür hier anklicken
anschauen und neugier zone abonnieren
und achtung neuer link der alte
funktioniert nicht mehr
wir berichten am 20 juli zwölf stunden
lang live hier aus dem space von der
mondlandung vor 50 jahren
wenn er nichts verpassen wollt dann
klickt hier oben und merkt euch den
stream also wer schon mal geklickt hat
den neuen stil vor
um 21 uhr am samstag den 20 juli geht es
los bis dann bleibt dran